En el vídeo titulado
"Completando el Cuadrado"
estuve diciendo que todo
lo que es la ecuación cuadrática,
es completar esencialmente
un binomio cuadrado
o mejor dicho un atajo para completar el cuadrado,
y tenía la impresión
de que había hecho esta demostración anteriormente
pero ahora me doy cuenta de que no lo había hecho,
así que déjenme demostrarles
la ecuación cuadrática
completando el cuadrado.
Digamos que tengo una ecuación cuadrática
muy en general
digamos que esto es
ax cuadrada más bx más "c" igual a 0.
Esta es una ecuación cuadrática,
muy en general,
y por supuesto,
voy a suponer que esta,
este número "a", pues no es 0,
porque si fuera 0,
esto ya no aparece
y me queda una ecuación lineal
y no me interesa ahorita
resolver ecuaciones lineales.
Así que
si tengo esta ecuación cuadrática,
déjenme quitar esta "c" de este lado
y pasarla del lado derecho.
Simplemente tenemos
ax cuadrada
más bx y si restamos "c" de ambos lados,
me queda aquí
que "c" se cancela
y acá me queda -"c",
entonces
como dije en el video,
no nos gusta...
en el video de
"Completando el Cuadrado",
no nos gusta tener una "a"
que esté al lado de la "x" cuadrada,
entonces puedo dividir entre esa "a",
y puedo dividir porque no es 0,
entonces,
si dividimos entre esa "a",
lo que nos va a quedar es,
"x" cuadrada
más "b"
entre ax
y déjenme dejar aquí un espacio,
esto va a ser igual a -"c" sobre "a".
Simplemente lo que hice
fue dividir entre "a" de ambos lados.
Ahora lo que voy a hacer
es completar el cuadrado,
el binomio cuadrado,
es decir,
de este lado izquierdo
tengo algo de la forma "x" cuadrada
más algo "x"
y yo voy a querer sumarle algo aquí, de tal suerte, que lo que me quede del lado izquierdo
sea un binomio al cuadrado,
es decir algo de la forma "x" más algo, al cuadrado,
y si recordamos muy bien
qué es eso de "x" más algo al cuadrado,
por ejemplo tenemos
"x" más "a", un numerito al cuadrado,
esto es
"x" cuadrada más 2 veces ax
más
"a" cuadrada.
Entonces yo esencialmente lo que quiero hacer
es sumar algo aquí para que
me quede de esta forma,
que sea un binomio al cuadrado
y lo pueda yo factorizar de la siguiente forma.
Entonces,
¿qué es lo que yo le tengo que sumar?
Yo lo que tengo que sumar es
si nos damos cuenta 2a
debe ser "b" entre "a",
quiere decir que este número "a"
es la mitad de "b" sobre "a",
entonces lo que yo voy a tener que hacer,
es sumarle
la mitad de "b" sobre "a"
pero debe ser al cuadrado
¿verdad?
Porque aquí aparece al cuadrado,
entonces va a ser
vamos a sumar
"b" sobre "a"
y la mitad de eso todo esto,
al cuadrado,
pero si lo sume del lado izquierdo,
para que se mantenga la igualdad
debo sumarlo también
del lado derecho.
Entonces esto lo sumamos,
y ahí quedó.
Entonces,
¿qué es lo que obtuvimos?
Obtuvimos que del lado izquierdo
justamente ya está expresado de esta forma,
entonces puedo irme
hacia el lado izquierdo de esta igualdad,
esto lo vamos a ver como "x" más
la raíz cuadrada del número que sumé
que es "b" sobre 2a
todo esto al cuadrado
¿Verdad?
Y eso será igual
a lo que me quedó del lado derecho,
pero lo que me quedó del lado derecho,
si por ejemplo,
simplificamos esto de aquí,
esto es
"b" cuadrada sobre 4a cuadrada,
simplemente eleve al cuadrado
el numerador y el denominador.
Entonces aquí es "b" cuadrada
y 2a
todo eso al cuadrado
es 4a cuadrada.
Entonces lo que voy a hacer aquí,
es sacar
un denominador común,
que en este caso sería 4a cuadrada ¿verdad?,
porque
4a cuadrada es divisible entre 4a  cuadrada
y también entre "a".
Entonces
4a cuadrada entre "a" es 4a
que si lo multiplicamos por -"c"
me queda -4a
por "c"
y luego 4a cuadrada entre 4a cuadrada por "b" cuadrada, simplemente es,
"b" cuadrada
¿verdad?
Simplemente,
lo que uno puede hacer es,
es distribuir esta,
esta división
¿Ok? Ahora lo que voy a hacer
es tomar la raíz cuadrada de ambos lados,
y si tomamos la raíz cuadrada
de ambos lados
pues del lado izquierdo simplemente
se va a cancelar esto ¿verdad?
Simplemente me queda "x" más "b"
sobre 2a
será igual a la raíz cuadrada de este cociente,
pero la raíz cuadrada de este cociente,
es la raíz
o el cociente de cada una de las raíces,
entonces simplemente va a ser
tomar la raíz cuadrada
de simplemente....
voy a cambiar el orden,
va a ser "b" cuadrada menos 4ac,
sobre la raíz cuadrada
de 4a cuadrada que es
2a
pero al tomar la raíz cuadrada es importante
que pueda ser tanto la positiva o la negativa
tenemos 2 posibles valores
que cumplen eso
Entonces ya casi acabamos
porque vamos a tener
que si restamos de ambos lados
"b" entre 2a
vamos a tener que "x"
es igual a "b" sobre 2a
y aquí va a ser más o menos
la raíz cuadrada de
"b" cuadrada menos 4ac
"b" cuadrada -4ac sobre
2a
Entonces como realmente tenemos el mismo,
el mismo denominador,
podemos sumarlo perfectamente,
¿y qué es lo que obtenemos?
que "x" es igual a "b"
más o menos
la raíz de "b" cuadrada
menos 4ac,
todo eso dividido
sobre 2a,
y esa,
esa es la famosa fórmula cuadrática.
Así que ahí ya lo tenemos,
ya la demostramos
y la demostramos sólo de completar
un cuadrado de...
en este lado.
Espero que esto les haya parecido algo interesante,
nos vemos en el próximo video.